I think there's little question that heatwaves
are becoming more frequent and they're getting
longer and they're getting hotter and one of
the questions we always get is what can you
do about it? I think there's obvious answers
you want to stay inside and out of the heat as
much as possible, but you're really also got
to think about your hydration. Even if you
are a young healthy person think about hydrating
throughout the day and if you're outside really
making sure you're amping up your hydration to
at least a cup every 20 minutes. Think about
lighter meals through the day that can help
you stay cooler especially at night as can
avoiding alcohol in the evening. Also, when you
think about heat also think about the humidity.
You want to cool your environment but also you
want to take out as much humidity as possible,
that lets the sweat off your skin actually
evaporate and cool you. And finally,
still exercise, still be active but probably
frame shift those things to earlier in the day.